I love this guy love this guy he's like
a brother to me I Love You Man we've
been feeling the love for piano since
the early 90s onset of Bill & Ted's
bogus journey Ted do you really me how
many fingers am I about to hold up the
film series also starring Alex winter
turned Keanu into one of the biggest
movie stars the obstinate decade Point
Break the film is it's a different you
know when I read the script I thought
you know it's just got its own energy
they jump out of airplanes they write
huge waves it's an FBI agent kill people
that's a bad guy bad guy so that's cool
Kiana's career took him from surfing in
Point Break to starring alongside Sandra
Bullock in speed she's a complete damsel
in distress and though the pair never
did it in real life
piano recently admitted on Ellen that
their chemistry was real obviously
didn't know I had a crush on her
I've heard relationships based on
intense experiences never work I'll have
to base it on sex in five years after
speed piano in his career bull's eyes
it's a film called The Matrix
before the release of the major XC gave
et a special tour of the set in
Australia but I'm those things it's the
synthesizing of machine and flesh and
you see that the wires here are blue and
red and kind of an ecto skeleton with
the [ __ ] veins and arteries and the
machine is kind of I don't know a beetle
that's spider the matrix spawned two
successful sequels and Kino has since
continued his reign as one of
Hollywood's biggest action stars in the
John wick franchise he's trying to catch
someone this kind of exact nut revenge
but they've killed his dog and stolen
his car and his wife has passed away dog
was a gift but
they killed the dog I'm gonna keep
asking if I'm back yeah I'm thinking on
back in this film you're kicking ass
like it's insane
I'm trying thank you for trying killing
it the modest actor is famous for being
one of the nicest guys in showbiz he
quietly took a pay cut in the Matrix
sequels so that the special-effects
creators could get more money he also
has been secretly donating money to
children's hospitals for years and just
look at the gentlemanly way he takes
pictures with his female fans boyfriend
how do we feel about that I've been what
you've been dubbed the internet's
boyfriend everyone is just kind of
gushing over you on the internet you
didn't know that yet no and though he
laughed off his title as the Internet's
boyfriend to that people magazine
reporter he seems happily in love with
his real-life partner Alexandra grant up
next canna will star in the sequels for
both of the matrix and villain Ted even
though he and Alex never thought a third
film would ever happen
go Ted three who knows I don't know if
there'll be any of the studios that we
all the studios that we seem to get
involved with crumble so I think if it
ever gets to three there probably won't
be Hollywood left and there probably
won't be any distribution companies to
love to distribute the movies